for three years I tried fill-in to  universities so I applied jobs for 30  times got rejected  I went for a please listen no you're not  good I went to either even the KFC when  KFC came to check up do I say 24 people  went for the job 23 people accepted I  was the only guy and we went for please  5 people fall of them accepted I was the  only guy did I receive it  I applied for Harvard for 10 times  rejected I know you read it and then I  told myself somebody I should go teach  there we have a secret success just like  Open Sesame  is a secret code for Alibaba the secret  code for everybody's keep your tree  alive because it might come true someday  this is what the secret code you just  watched two amazing clips from Jack Ma  take the next 3 minutes and think about  how you can apply them to your business  and your life believe  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]